Vor
13,8 milliarden jahren ist das universum wohl entstanden
und zwar mit dem urknall das war der anfang das gilt als gesichert
doch wie sieht sein tod aus wie wird das universum wohl zu ende gehen dazu gibt es verschiedene
theorien mal droht dem universum ein dunkles und leeres und kaltes schicksal mal stirbt es von einer sekunde auf die andere
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp messenger
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt die fünf spannendsten szenarien zum absoluten finale des
universums so oder so es wird spektakulär herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Seit seiner entstehung und dem urknall dehnt sich das universum
aus und es gibt
vereinfacht gesagt zwei kräfte die sein schicksal bestimmen zum einen der schwung des urknalls der es
auseinandertreibt und zum anderen die materie die sich in ihm befindet und seine expansion abbremst wie wird es enden welche kraft wird gewinnen
doch neben diesen beiden kräften existierte aber noch die
hypothetische dunkle energie
forschungsteams weltweit
verstehen sie noch nicht wirklich doch sie agiert wohl wie eine art anti schwerkraft die das universum
auseinandertreibt
zudem wird sie wohl umso größer je mehr sich der raum aus denen eventuell wird ja auch diese mysteriöse dunkle energie in zukunft
übermächtig dann würde sie nicht nur sterne und galaxien aufeinander
reisen sondern auch atome und moleküle und zwar so lange bis nur noch strahlung und und zerlegbare teilchen
existieren hier kommen für euch jetzt fünf weitere spannende theorien zum ende des universums
szenario eins der big trick fangen wir an mit dem sogenannten big trick demnach
befindet sich das weltall in einem meter stabilen zustand quasi wie ein ball der zwischen zwei bergen im tal
hin und her rollt wie zieht man dann die quantenphysik mit 1 ist dieser ball allerdings nicht nur in diesem einen teil
stattdessen gibt es ihn in allen tälern dieser welt nach einer gewissen wahrscheinlichkeit
verteilung theoretisch wäre es also auch möglich dass er sich sehr plötzlich in einem deutlich tieferen teil befindet und darf ohne
zeitverlust genau dieses szenario
sich auch auf das universum übertragen solch einen phasenübergang ist statistisch gesehen sogar jederzeit möglich und er
passiert einfach so quasi von selbst weil der erreichte zustand
energetisch gesehen günstiger ist denn auch wenn wir menschen den jetzigen zustand als grundzustand
empfinden ist es wahrscheinlich dass ein noch geringeres energieniveau existiert beim beispiel des balles also ein noch tieferes tal
teams aus teilchen physikern und physikerin vermuten sogar dass solch einen phasenübergang bereits schon einmal stattgefunden hat und zwar
milliardstel sekunden nach dem urknall als einig fällt den raum gefüllt hat durch die interaktion von explosionen und elementarteilchen
haben die teilchen dann erst ihre masse bekommen doch wie wahrscheinlich ist es dass demnächst erneut ein
phasenübergang stattfindet dazu haben wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler aus dänemark bereits
2013 geforscht in ihrer studie ging es vor allem um die frage wie stabil der grund zustand des universums
ist ihre ergebnisse lassen darauf schließen dass es sich tatsächlich
deutlich stärker auf der instabilen seite befindet als man bisher dachte und das lässt die wahrscheinlichkeit
eines solchen phasen übergangs natürlich ansteigen doch ihre forschung gibt nicht eins zu eins
antwort auf die frage wie das universum ende denn in ihren berechnungen stecken einige
unsicherheiten beispielsweise was die dunkle materie und die dunkle energie angeht das ist ja absolut nicht gesichert ob und wie sie
existieren für beide gab es bisher
keinerlei nachweise sie sind hypothetisch zweite szenario der kältetod
einige fachleute sind der ansicht dass sich das universum immer schneller aussehen für das wir in etwa 13 milliarden jahren nichts mehr
außer unseren nachbarn galaxien im universum sehen werden kleine objekte die milchstraße und die magellanschen wolken
beispielsweise werden lang miteinander
verschmelzen und schwarze löcher bilden zudem wird es immer weniger sterne geben das alles basiert auf der annahme dass
unser universum durch die sogenannte kosmologische konstante
dominiert wird diese wurde von albert einstein ins leben gerufen damit seine allgemeine relativitätstheorie
tatsächlich ein statisches universum so wie gewünscht denn zu seiner zeit war man sich einig dass sich das universum wieder
zusammenzieht noch aus sind einige zeit später
erkannte man dann dass sich das weltall doch ausdehnt und die konstante wurde zwischenzeitlich abgeschafft
mittlerweile hat man sie ins standardmodell der kosmologie
zurückbefördert dabei ist man sich allerdings immer noch uneinig ob sie tatsächlich konstant ist dritte szenario
der begriff einer dritten theorie zufolge könnte das universum auch durch einen sogenannten
big rig sterben und zwar wenn sich das universum so krass aus den dass es quasi zerrissen wird
in der theorie könnte das tatsächlich so passieren nämlich dann wenn die dunkle energie einen noch extremeren
negativen druck aufweist als wir bisher annehmen doch es gibt auch einige fakten die gegen den begräbt als das große finale des
universums sprechen vierte szenario der blick wann das große
knirschen den modellen namens big crunch zufolge könnte genau das
gegenteil von big wird passieren das universum würde sich den markt zusammen ziehen und dann
schlussendlich in einem and knall enden es würde also immer enger werden das universum quasi als eine art kosmische
schrottpresse und zwar bis es so heiß und nicht wäre wie zu zeiten des urknalls dafür sind zwei voraussetzungen
nötig einen phasenübergang müsste dafür sorgen dass die dunkle energie verschwindet und sich in materie umwandelt außerdem müsste das universum eine
positive krümmung aufweisen denn dann würde die materie die ausdehnung des universums in eine kontraktion
verwandeln was ist wirklich zum big crunch kommen würde könnte danach ein big points stattfinden also wieder ein urknall
der einen neuen zyklus des universums beginnen lassen würde fünfte
szenario unfall mit einem nachbar
universum möglich ist auch dass das universum vor seinem natürlichen tod einen unfall hat und mit einem nachbar universum
zusammenstößt es gibt fachleute die davon ausgehen dass so etwas in regelmäßigen abständen
passiert ein physiker von der princeton university beispielsweise ist der meinung das ganze in unserer nähe ein zweites universum in höheren raumdimensionen
existiert demnach ist der urknall lediglich die innenansicht einer kollision mit unserem zwillings und
also um eine weitere kollision in zukunft würde für einen neuen
lebenszyklus des universums sorgen an all diesen szenarien wird weiter gefeilt noch ist rein gar nichts sicher alles hypothesen
gedankenspiele usw
und sobald
indizien für die ein oder andere theorie
veröffentlicht werden erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann
umgeht er die etwas
unzuverlässige abo box sie auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
vornehmen upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau locker vergessen heute es geht es übrigens um den
gefängnis blogger hier in berlin also im aktuellen video ja und hier geht es war damit dafür auch darauf blicken ist das universum ein supercomputer
bis dann
bleibt dran